[Music]  the entire  world is a collection of memoranda that  she did exist  and that i have lost her this is our  story  tessa's and mine we're like an addiction  to each other with equal parts pleasure  and pain you hurt me and i can't forgive  you  i want another chance  i'll try whatever it takes harden's your  son  but he is not without his challenges  [Music]  is he sorry can you hold the elevator  please  welcome to vance publishing she makes  quite the impression  wow  i didn't peg you as a bad boy type let  me ask you this  are you in love with him you're never  gonna trust me  trust you where has that ever gotten me  i thought that things were getting  better but i don't know how to fix it  there is no you're tessa anymore  [Music]  whatever our souls are made of isn't  mine are the same  there's no one else for me tessa noah  [Music]  you